Hi Guys, is this, is this working?
Yeah, that's good. Ah, look,
delight to be here.
It's great to see doctor draw off some
free whiskey on a Friday afternoon.
It's still gets people interested.
So, so delighted to be here.
I'm here just to tell you a little bit
about who we are, what we're trying to do.
Um,
and at the same time maybe in part some
nuggets of information linkedin to the
rich providence and heritage
of Dublin and Ireland in, uh,
the evolution of,
of global whiskey because there's lots
of hidden stories and messages that have
been lost along the way.
And um, we're lucky myself,
my brother would just the latest
generations of tailings involved in the
industry and we're trying to put our
own mark on it and we like to say we're
respectful to the past,
but we're confident that forge
in your future boss to do that,
you need to know where you've come
from. So, uh, just very, very quickly,
people don't know that actually whiskey
distillation comes from Ireland's a,
it was actually the Irish monks who
traveled around the world and they saw in
the Middle East and the Mediterranean,
uh,
the curious process of distillation using
a lambic steels, making essential oils,
uh,
making older v and they
took that technology back to
Ireland and we didn't have
the same crops,
but what there was,
there was lots of barley and
they soon figured out dot.
The resulting spirits are
illiquid HUD, medicinal values.
And, uh, that technology,
uh,
moved all around the world.
And so I went to Scotland
and went to everywhere else,
but it was very much a mom and pop
is very, very small production.
So when Larry was, was on farms, um, and
really catering for the local community,
um, but a couple of different
things changed, uh, from
the 18th and 19th century.
Our family first started in 1782.
I didn't small cross distillery in the
city center of Dublin and one of he go to
ones and I, an owner, the small
distilleries came to giants.
I really drove the last golden era for
Irish whiskey in the 19th century when
Irish whiskey and Dominique is much
bigger and Scotch and much bigger than
American whiskey.
We,
dominator in 70% of all global experts
came out of the islands of our islands.
Um, and there was a reason for that
because we had, uh, even back in the 17th,
18th century, a quality reputation
was always seen as smooth and very,
very drinkable. Um, and uh, one thing
happened at the start of the 19th century.
It was the act of union
with the British empire,
which was not so good for the country,
but great for Irish whiskey sales. Uh,
because all of a sudden it opened up all
the markets around the world, uh, to, uh,
Irish whiskey and, um, and also led
to a lot of foreign direct investment.
So a lot of money came into Ireland.
Um,
and at that time Dublin was the second
richest city in the whole of the British
empire. Um, and a lot of money went into
whiskey distillation in particular. Um,
and because of the industrial revolution,
the smaller distilleries could
become calm, much bigger. Um,
and it was quite interesting in that,
and when you think of distillation,
you think of rolling hills,
you're thinking of locks and all that.
In Ireland it was urban,
it was in city centers because it was
linked to the ports and it could export
around the world.
So there was very,
very different than what
was happening in Scotland's.
But unfortunately we lost our way. Um, um,
I think a success breeds arrogance and
we didn't adopt to modern technology.
Um, uh, on one or two other things
happened in the 20th century,
won the war of independence. Um, uh,
which was great again for the country,
but dread full of for Irish whiskey
sales cause it's so a stowed away all the
routes to market that we hods. Um,
I'm from the 1930s to the 1990s.
Uh,
it was a dark day for Irish whiskey cause
the last big export market was the u s
and they prohibition. So it was like a
car crash and we fell off a cliff. Um,
um,
and a lot of the old brands and a lot of
the olds at distilleries slowly slipped
away.
Uh,
and what's interesting and what's unique,
uh,
really about our city and the
city that you guys find yourself.
This is the cradle of urban whiskey
distillation. Uh, it was here in the city,
um, because as I said, it wasn't,
these rural distilleries
are driving that golden era.
It was distilleries in the city center
of Dublin and really in the area called
the liberties,
which was outside of the city wall.
And the reason why it was called the
liberties because you're at liberty to do
whatever the hell you wanted and was
famous for manufacturing. It was a,
for breweries,
it was for a distilleries was for linen
and for four bottles and all so forth.
But, uh, uh,
the one that stood the test of time was
a distilleries and breweries and there
was so much production in one
square kilometer in the liberties.
It was called the Golden Triangle.
And it was where majority of the
whiskey sold in the last golden era, uh,
of Irish whiskey came from.
Um,
but it was a very dark day in 1976 from
the last Dublin distilleries showed the
stores, uh, when powers a show,
the stores and all the production was
consolidated down into worn distillery in
cork, in the Middleton distillery.
So from the 1976 onwards,
all that rich heritage and provenance
and all the stories and characters that
we're linkedin to making whiskey in
our city. So he slipped away, uh,
until recently of, uh,
so where are we now?
We are in a new golden
era for Irish whiskey.
I'm Irish whiskey since in 1990s has
been the fastest growing spirits category
in the world.
Um,
as a new generation that people discover
the joys of Irish whiskey and Irish
whiskey because of our climate and the
way we make it, it's a little bit lighter,
it's a little bit more accessible
and it's, it's a perfect gateway,
a spirit into whiskey in general.
And it's, uh, everything is cyclical.
So they say you don't drink
what your parents drink,
but you might drink what
your grandparents drink. Uh,
and it's really ours whiskeys,
chance to shine. Um, and, uh,
it's still only at the early
stages of segmentation. For years,
there's only been a handful of
distilleries. So in 2012, when I set up,
there was only four distilleries.
Now there's 20 plus and more
coming very quickly behind.
So it's going to change.
It's going to evolve.
It's going to be a proper category with
lots of different styles and expression
for people to discover
it. Um, and, uh, it's, uh,
hopefully going to double from where
we are now, uh, over the next 10 years.
And why is it happening? It's really
down to consumer behavior. Consumer,
younger people like all your
good selves here. Um, um,
much more progressive.
They don't stick with bronze.
They like to discover something new. They
want to find something that's relevant,
that can connect, um, um, to himself. Um,
and they're enjoying whiskey, um,
of every kind in different ways. Um,
before our Irish whiskey was very
much, um, Irish coffees, you know,
around the holidays for, you know, uh,
Irish American foundries and so forth.
But it's changing.
It's part of a cocktail.
It's being used and drunk and many
different ways. Um, and straight, uh, uh,
of course. Um, and, uh, the Asian
for like growth is the u s market.
Um,
so it was a market that put the final
nail in the coffin of Irish whiskey a at
the start of the 20th century.
But it's driving, um, uh,
let's say the evolution and the
revolution of the category now, um,
it's grown by over 600% the last
10 years. Uh, but it's for us,
the premiumization at the higher end
of the market is the one that's growing
very, very fast. But why are people
drinking? And I told, said, um,
sense of discovery, it's become
part of popular culture. Um,
but at the core is the taste.
People enjoy the taste of Irish
whiskey are lonely, miserable,
temperate climates is good for one thing.
And that's producing, you know, as I say,
a soft climate producers are soft
whiskey. But it's true. It's true.
Because if you go view,
took a distillery that's in our
islands and you made the spirit,
but you mature that in
the highlands of Scotland,
or in Kentucky or in Taiwan or in Japan,
anywhere else,
it will be totally different.
The cask and the maturation
deliver 60 to 70% of the flavor.
And what's distinctive about
Irish whiskey is the temperate,
soft climate that
producers, um, limited, uh,
let's say movement of the ward because Oh,
costs are porous and they
deliver majority of it.
So it's environmental influence. So,
so when you take of Irish whiskey,
it's because of,
you know,
we don't get to go to the beach
too often and we have to, you know,
always carry a,
a raincoat witness,
but it delivers exceptional
quality whiskey. Um,
and when I set up a,
in 2012, um, you know,
I had worked in a company
called Cudi distillery.
It'd been set up on my father in 1987.
Uh,
it was the first new distillery in
arms over a hundred years. Um, and, uh,
we tried to revive a lot
of old, famous brands. Um,
and I went around the u s and all around
the world trying to promote them on ice
off myself, the emergence of
crafts, spirits, craft beer,
people going back into urban centers to
try and make things and create brands
that were relevant to the
people that around there. Um,
on the planting the seed in my head.
Um,
and when my father decided to sell
the company he was in in 2011,
2012 and it's beam Suntory to
kill beg and Brian went to dam.
But it allowed me a chance to take all
these little nuggets of information and
the things that I really wanted to do
and really attack the category in my own
way. And my vision was to
bring a more contemporary,
more modern, uh, representation
of what Dublin and Ireland is, uh,
rather than the traditional rolling hills,
red setters and all that kind of
still for me as a modern owner,
didn't really connect me and just kind of
like, you know, it's like going to, oh,
Carol's gift shop and you see all
up how do you stuff it's not real.
It's not really what's going on.
So I thought that was an opportunity
to rep present Arland and Dublin in a
modern way and put my own mark on it,
but do it in a way that
was very relevant to me.
And to go right back to where I found
the first started, the studying,
which just in the city with Dublin,
um, and these are the other players.
So Pernod Ricard, um, the
biggest player by long way,
Jameson is a phenomenally success
story. Uh, obviously amazing. Um,
but we won't go into that because
like you're talking about, uh,
William grinds and Sonia
they own totem or Jew,
they bought out a good few years ago now,
but they're the largest privately owned
as Scotch whiskey company and the Igo
biggest drinks company in the world.
You used to own a and was at the
time they subsequently flipped it a,
I bought a premium Tequila, but they're
coming back into it as well. Um, so,
so the concept was to do something
different and to do something very unique.
And that was to, to come back to the
city center of Dublin and do it. So, um,
as I said, all of that being
contemporary, urban, innovative,
celebrating my own unique providence and
doing something a little bit different.
Um, but at the core of it was to get back
into production as soon as possible. Um,
but also as we said,
whiskey is a very traditional category.
You can't treat whiskey like a white
spirits like vodka or gin because of all
the history and so forth.
If you look at all the old bronze or
there'd be around for hundreds of years.
So you're competing against that and a
certain consumer expectations of what it
should look like. So, so we see ourselves
as the disrupter of Irish whiskey,
but at the same time, we're
quite, you probably go, yeah,
you're quite traditional because
that's what people expect.
And if you go too far,
people actually lose credibility and
they think you're overcompensating for
something crop in the wall. Um, so,
so what we have done is, uh, we are,
let's say a celebrating the past. We've
gone with the old style dark bottle. Um,
it's the way that they would have been
able to make last back in the 19th
century, early 20th century. They
can't make clear white Flint.
They just didn't have the capability to
do it. So if you see old bottles, uh,
you'll see they're all like this.
So I have to go to Italy to
find someone that made it, um,
but then have a standard label that has,
you know,
modern cues that people would expect.
And our symbolism is fees.
A Phoenix rising from the potstill to
symbolize the revival of distilling in the
city, but also a revival of our
family's involvement in the category.
And our tagline is the spirit of Dublin.
And the reason why we say
that the spirit of Dublin,
it's not about making alcohol in it.
It's trying to capture that unique DNA
that makes Dublin the city that it is.
It's a bit gritty. He's got his own
sense of humor. He's got a school,
just got its bad points, but it's
very resilient. Uh, you know,
there's a reason why you guys are here is
the reason why, um, uh, Google have, uh,
the European Middle
Eastern headquarters here,
it's because of the people and you know,
the environment that it creates.
And I want to capture that and try
and put that into a bottle of whiskey.
So that's what the spirit
of Dublin means to us. Um,
and uh, as you said, we're
urban centers through the ages.
So a Dava is not what our family does.
It really looked like a,
what actually happened
was our family distillery.
We went through a couple
of different generations.
It got assumed into much larger
distillery that was set setup by William
Jemison, who was John Jameson song and
became the Marble Lane, this theory.
So it was the Saudis put a lot smaller.
And this is our new distillery today, um,
first new distillery in
Dublin for over 125 years. Um,
it took me nearly three years to get a
bill just for planning reasons and so
forth, even though it has all
that history and all that,
the kind of an old
distilleries based around it.
And one of the biggest breweries
in the world. And Guinness,
it's still was exceedingly difficult to
get Dublin city council to back me to be
able to build a distillery cause
they want to move industry.
Like manufacturing is dirty manufacturing
as they see it out of the city.
So it was a fight in her hands,
but lucky enough it was worth the effort
to get us because it's our brand tone
and as you can see is we like
to say we fit into the, the,
the Palette of materials that
are famous around the liberties,
but it's a modern or disturbing. You
didn't want to create a pastiche kind of,
you can't recreate history.
Let's create a new history.
And that's more interesting to me and I
think that's more interesting for people.
And if you come and see us,
and that's where we are. Again,
new market square where we are is a
part of the old parts of the city.
It has so much heritage and stories
I won't go into today. But, uh, um,
our previous family distillery, uh, was
up around there, so not too far away. Um,
but we're urban prophetess dinners.
And when you come to see our distillery,
the hero is manufacturing. You actually
see a real manufacturing, uh, um,
a location. It's not a vis center where
the distillery is a distillery would,
a visitor center.
So it's a medium sized distillery with
real people making real whiskey seven
days a week, uh, bringing
back that smells,
the sounds and the environmental
experience. And once you see it,
it's a very simple process. It's, we
made the same way for hundreds of years,
if not thousands of years. Um, um,
it's literally makeup hair and then
you distill your actually extract
impurities, extract water, and
you're left with your spirits,
which then you have to mature
for three years in the day. Um,
and what we focus on is being
different. So we're small. We're, we're,
we're tiny. We're like a, I
wouldn't like to say a pimple on a,
on the arse of an elephant.
We're quite small.
Maybe our competitors see
us like that bullet. Uh, um,
well we want to do was we
didn't want to take away,
we're not trying to rob
volume from the marketing.
We're trying to create choice for people.
When they want to discover something
interesting with it in the category,
they can come to us and
hopefully we're different.
Our liquid is different and we take a
lot of pride in the liquid that goes into
it because the one thing I learned at
an early age was you call it a case of
worldclass whiskey. To get
in the game, to win the game,
you have to create a world class brand.
And we're, we're working on that. We're,
we're not there yet,
but we wanted to create very,
very different tasting whiskeys so that
you can have any other brands out there
and ours that will stand out and hopefully
sign up for the right reasons. Um,
what you have to have everything
else that goes with it. So,
so we have a premium price. Um,
um, versus let's say we're in 25,
30% higher than the market leader.
We have differentiated packaging and
hopefully our story is different as well
and bringing it all together.
Hopefully we can create something that's,
as you say, a little, a little off
center. So this is our, our small batch,
just as our kind of our flagship product.
And the reason why we went with this,
because 90% of Irish whiskey
sales are blended whisky.
It's a blend of grain and malt whiskey.
Grain whiskey is made from corn
or maize. It's very light. Um,
and blending it with heavier style
potstill or single malt makes it more
accessible, easier to drink,
and it's cheaper as well. Um,
so 90% of all our ish whiskey sold is
that type and that's what people expect
and that's what they get used to it.
But we came out a little bit different.
We said,
well look,
let's treat that blended whiskey respect
and put an interesting barrels and
treat it like it was a single
malt and our small batch was born.
So we take a grain,
a malt whiskey that's been aged four
and six years in Bourbon barrels.
We blend it together and then we let him
marry in Rome barrels for an extra year
or so and the parts,
this extra layer of flavor and we
bottled at 46% or 92 proof. Um,
um,
which captures all the natural flavors
and so does up that it takes experience,
but it tastes like what people
expect and they joy already. So,
so creating a ladder of different
things to get people, um, um,
discovering something new and we created
a whole range of different expressions
and for people. So ranging
from our spirits of dove
and poaching, which is new,
make spirits straight off the still. So,
uh, um, it's traditionally very strong.
We only bought that 55%,
but it's still puts hair on your chest.
It doesn't put it on your head.
Unfortunately.
I've tried many times to
our Teeling trinity range,
which is a,
our small batch.
And then we break the individual
components into a bottling of single grain
whiskey and single malts,
again,
using very innovative casks
to impart a unique flavor.
And then we're lucky we have some of the
oldest are single malts available and
we've created an arrange of
different expressions, um,
all the way up to a 33 year old,
which to me is a piece of arch whiskey
history that we're just very lucky to be
able to celebrate.
And ties into celebrating the past,
but at the same time doing something
different. Um, what have you achieved?
You know, it's a six years now, so it's a,
uh, better than something where now, uh,
though we're the fastest growing Irish
whiskey domestically, which I think,
I think a lot of pride in.
So to be a real brand,
you've got to be relevant
to people on your,
in your backyard and put a
lot of time and effort in.
And Irish whiskey 10 years ago,
no one gave it down.
It was very much focused on bigger brands.
They didn't really want to discover
anything else, but it's totally evolved.
It's totally changed now.
Every bar, every restaurant,
it takes pride in their back bar and
particularly Irish whiskey are our SGN and
everything else that's going
on. So, so it's changed a lot,
but we're delighted to be part of that
evolution and we're exporting to over 60
international markets, but it's
like the 80 20 rule, the u s uh,
global travel retail,
some bigger markets like that,
that drives most of our volume. Um, um,
and we'll continue to do so we're seeding
in Asia and, um, some emerging markets,
but we're in probably a little bit
more for when people already know Irish
whiskey,
getting the one to discover something new.
That's where we come in and we've
won over 175 international awards,
which definitely you take a lot
of pride in. Um, um, and, uh,
we'll continue to focus on a one bottle
at a time and we'd like to say, uh,
we put our bottling date on it,
uh,
and I get to put my signature on
it cause I actually have the, the,
the rice to joy, the obligation to
sign off every batch before we do it.
So it sounds great,
but you had a,
let's say a busy weekend and you come in
on a Monday morning and we're like, oh,
we have to bottle taste this
and you're drinking costume.
Whiskey can sense a lot more
romantic than it actually is. Um,
but it's still, it's still, it's still not
a bad job, so I can't complain, but I do,
I could play it all the time. Um, and, uh,
we've had over 300,000 visitors.
True. Um, which is amazing,
which is great because we don't have
money for global advertising budgets.
What we want is that
experiential marketing,
so people to call them and experience
us, meet the people, young,
passionate people we have working for us,
um,
understand what we're all about and
then take that home with them no matter
where they are in the world. So, uh,
it's a key thing and that was part of
the reason we have to fight together
distillery because we wanted
that experience side of, of, of,
of the business as well. Um, and
you'll be delighted to know, um,
I'm talking a lot about
the small batch and,
and I'll talk a little bit the Ciliary,
we have some free passes and some whiskeys
there for you guys to take with you
so you can really experience
what we're all about as well. Um,
and where are we now? In 2018, um,
since I started coming to the category
is doubled. Well if nearly doubled,
um, segmentations accelerating, um,
and what we had before and we were limited
by supply going forward from where we
are now,
it's going to be limited by demand.
So it puts a lot more onus on us to to
let's say a perfect our digital marketing
and odor to is that we can leverage
to connect and tell our story in a
meaningful way to our target
demographic. Uh, on our glue.
Our goal for the next three to four years
is to really be that global discovery,
Irish whiskey driving the
premiumization of Irish whiskey.
Not trying to be the next
Jansen or [inaudible] or
anything like that is really
helped the category evolve and to
give that choice so that when you go,
no matter where you go in the world,
rather it one bottle of Irish whisky,
you'll see a range of Irish whiskey.
And that's the opportunity.
That's the challenge.
At the same time, um,
and it's getting more challenging because
this is what's happening and there's
definitely a revolution going on.
There's no shortage of
entrepreneurship in our own.
That's the one thing I can definitely say
is that everyone sees the opportunity.
I'm not sure if they're all going
to be able to grasp it or not.
So the ones in the red where the
regional distilleries, when I settle,
when I set up with that were there,
the ones in the green are the ones
that are there. Um, um, um, now,
and the ones in the black
are some of the ones,
there's even more that are going to
come up. So it's always very exciting.
It's very noisy.
Um,
hopefully if everyone focused on doing
something a little bit different,
a little bit more interesting and
embrace their own story and location,
the future looks very,
very bright. So Shinay
[inaudible]
am I on track? Got Y'all on the
head. Is Roxhill loads. Question. So,
so Jack,
thank you so much for coming.
This has been like a very interesting
talk that I've witnessed the spite of the
talks at Google team. Um, and we're
talking about whiskey. But my,
my first question,
my very serious first question is,
have you ever been drunk
on Teeling whiskey?
I would you recommend the experience?
Oh my gosh.
Well,
I can tell you my first
experience with whiskey was
not the best. Um, uh, you know,
was it because he wasn't dealing with
the problem with people who don't maybe
know whiskey and how they drink it is
that if you try and drink it like wine
or beer, you'll drink it too fast.
Um, um, you have to drink in a different
way. So you sip it, you appreciate it.
So if you're doing it too fast, it will
hit you like a steam train unforeseen.
When I was growing up, no one
told me that. Uh, and uh, yeah,
I can really knock your socks off.
I know we're all about drinking less and
drinking better. So, um, it's a, it's,
it's about more flavor,
more character and enjoying
and appreciating the whiskey
rahter than drinking it
just to get drunk. But the medicinal
benefits of it are a very relaxing,
it's good to have, especially after
a hard week and work like, you know,
let's go wait to, to unwind. Yeah.
Yeah. So it's about drinking less,
but drinking better. Yeah. Yeah. You know,
so that's very philosophical for whiskey.
Now. Uh, well it's, it's not, it's, it's
happened a lot in different categories.
It's happened, but it's a
tequila. It's good. It used
to be always just a shot. Um,
part of the experience of,
you know, I wouldn't say
college experience for people.
Um, now it's, you know, you're
look at Petroleum Tequila, it's,
it's all about understanding
the current effort.
It goes into creating the products and
if you understand that you'll appreciate
it a little bit more in your
drinking in a different way as well.
Thank you. So you definitely recommend,
um, I just wanted to know, so
I definitely recommend drinking tea
rescue, but not too much that, uh,
you make per life decisions.
Okay.
Um, I'm really curious. I have
a question for you as a CEO. Um,
if you could describe for us your worst
or your best day in business while
without being,
she's tough. Question.
Uh, yeah. Well, uh, um,
I'm lucky that we've had
some key landmark, um,
days along the journey. Um,
um, um, we're going this year,
2018 is a key landmark a year for,
for,
for us as a whiskey distillery
because it's three years in a day. Um,
and before you can legally sell it.
So,
so we're actually bottling up our very
first release of our Teeling single
potstill, which will be coming
available later in the year or so.
So it's amazing to have just a concept
that you've had floating around in your
head to actually, you
know, build this, um,
lay it down and let it mature over that
period of time and then see it come to
life. Um, so, uh, this year is
a, is a, is a big year for us,
but also it's like the original five year
business plan has, has, has, let's say,
happened and now we have to
reinvigorate yourself and go again.
So all of the things you want to do and
it's again, you know, just sitting back,
you know, how have a range of
all of our whiskeys win awards,
do all that kind of stuff like that.
We've done that.
So how would you refire the organization
to aspire to something bigger? Again,
a uneven myself. Um, um,
um, that's, this was a,
a key challenge in terms
of bonds, um, and days. Um,
I always find that the worst thing is
around people and sometimes, you know,
the challenge that's human resources
can happen. So, um, you know,
some bad decisions or how
did hiring and you know,
to be negative for the company and
so forth and creating, you know,
not the type of environment
for staff that you want. Um,
and there were some of the,
the the worst times for us,
but that's just normal in an organization.
Um,
but still I'm lucky is by far like,
you know,
it's like I struggle
sometimes to say like,
what was your worst decision or
what's the worst day hike for you?
I don't think of how to yet. Um, um,
uh, but it's been a real positive ions,
a enjoyable experience for me so far.
Um, my, my next question
is around legacy. Um,
so you're running a company
that has had a lot of history,
a lot of family history,
but at the same time you're running it
in the 21st century where things are
changing very rapidly. Um, so how
have you been able to marry the,
with the contemporary, so
retaining your, your core identity,
but then also adapting it for the, you
know, for, for the young games like us,
I'm not that old.
I used to say our target demographic was
21 to 35 now is it has to be 21 to 45,
like, you know, so, um, but, um, um,
I suppose in any kind of business where
your, your name is on the ball, hello are,
you know, it's gone through
lots of different generations.
There's a lot of pressure on ownership
on you to represent him the right way,
not screw up. Um, ours is a little
bit different in that, you know,
it's really a kind of revival of the
trademark and the history. Um, um,
so we're a little bit more,
that's a, uh, not as, uh,
hampered by some of the legacy issues.
But water we're trying to do is when
people think of Teeling or they hear the
name, think the old, like the whiskey,
you know, so that's where we want to go.
And uh, you know, I think, uh,
our, our, our wider family,
which is quite a small
achieving is unusual.
Arash name actually came from a vikings.
Norman's Sooni came to
Ireland's many years ago.
There's more teamings in
Hollins than anywhere else,
which I only found out once I set up
the company and they all kept phoning up
asking for a free bottles of
whiskey. So, uh, um, but, uh, no,
I think a, it's a, it's an amazing
opportunity that I've been given, um,
to, to quote our mark
back on dope. It was, um,
you know,
hopefully it can go through a couple of
different generations and carry on that
legacy too to make sense.
And my final question, so if you
have a question, just get ready. Um,
my final question is, when you were
speaking, you said that, um, two dates,
you've had about 300,000 visits us at the
distillery. That's a lot of people. Um,
and you also said something around
digital marketing and trying to, you know,
adapt for the digital age.
So really quick question.
Do you have an ad words
account? Yes. Okay.
Oh yeah. Yeah. It's a,
it's a, it's a key. Um, um,
I'm just joking,
but it is because the hardest thing is,
is in our industry,
there's so many. We don't have our
own distributors, so, you know,
we have distributors, independent
servers around the world. Um,
it's sometimes like Chinese whispers
about you're telling your story,
you say it to them and they
kind of go, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, you, I understand. They,
they've no idea what you're talking about.
And then they tell their sales guys who
didn't tell us the Barmah new tells then
to consumer and they kind of
lose that impact. So, you know,
modern digital communication,
cultural, all the noise.
So someone on their phone and find you on,
hopefully you understand what your
product is on that and what your brands,
thanks for pitching adwords,
but I'm going to use that in
my next client meetings. Um,
so are there questions
from the, Oh, perfect.
I'm the best question. Got
a big one. So no pressure.
Um, since we're here at
Google, I want to know like,
which is your favorite youtube channel
talking about whiskey. And one last thing,
what do you think about Conor McGregor?
Snoop
proper tall,
probably the first one is a guy called
Ralphy. Uh, I don't know if you know Rafi.
He's a, he's a serious
character, um, on, um,
he's been doing it for a long time. He
always, you must be out of for, you know,
way before, you know, the, the modern
and interesting in online reviews.
And he's very independent as well. He's
Scottish, which is a bit of an issue. Um,
so he is this a war few Irish
whiskey, but you know, I, I enjoy,
uh, the way he does his tasting.
Do you remember your score?
Uh, um, we've got a couple. Um,
I think we did reasonably
okay on the small batch.
I think he likes the older expressions.
They are seeing the multiple baker
he gives good Switzerland. So, um,
then Conor McGregor, it's kind of very,
it was interesting when they was, uh, uh,
because he sent in his negotiator
to us, a couple of, uh,
I would say maybe two years ago
ago, I thought our Tam and, Oh Beth,
who is the Russian Hower, he's a
MMA fighter as well, but he is, uh,
a friend of, of Connor on day. He was
looking at getting supply whiskey,
real negotiator,
you'll really go share.
I was 40 years cause he had no clothes
on his hand. And then he was like, oh,
he's starting small. Like, Yo, you're
like, oh they kill, maybe I can take them.
And I said, not a challenge. And uh,
he just finished a business degree
so he was going around and do,
so Connor has had an interest for awhile.
We pitched and idea of doing a very
limited high end kind of boring for him,
but he wanted something that was a little
bit more entry level, um, to kind of, uh,
you know, gosh or wider opportunity.
And it was something we couldn't do. Um,
and his launch just being for the
home, like, you know, it's a, it's,
it's the definitely generated
a lot of interest. Um, I, I,
I'd be interested to see how that interest
in teens over the weekends, you know,
but, uh, I was in a taxi and he's
an MMA fighter, the taxi driver,
and he said guaranteed going to knock
it out in the first round. And so, uh,
he's putting his own money on it, so, uh,
it could be an extra kick
for her first Muskie,
but I think more people talking about
Irish whiskey. It's good. Um, um, on,
you know, cause it's still at
the early stages I'll definition,
but we do something that's
quite different. And Connor,
hi. Thanks. First for your presentation,
really engaging or question around this
distillery on what you're producing in
there. So I've been to this distillery in
new market. It's very impressive. Setup.
The merchandise store, not like the
party like, or Carlos you mentioned. Um,
but you mentioned that you showed us an
Irish family of whiskeys and one of them,
my soul was the poaching.
Um,
so actually went to the launch of
this and it was paired with poachers,
an Irish gin to thought it
was really great that you're
supporting iris business.
Where do you see this in
terms of your target, Marcus,
and how can this become like a,
a drink,
like a cocktail or we're poaching or
just whiskey in Jerry w with poaching.
Yeah, we'll put, Geez,
I've been interested in pushing
for a long time because it is,
everyone in our islands
has some story about new,
mostly not code. We're poaching a, it
always comes out on special occasions,
weeks or you know, a stags or
all this kind of stuff like that.
Or someone has a bottle
somewhere underneath the ad.
The cadre are under the counter in the
seven up or whatever sort of bottle. Uh,
and I always thought it
was great opportunity to
represent it in a more modular,
um,
but it's hard because people don't,
I have to drink and it's a bit of a
novelty because it's so strong and the,
you're competing as odor,
you know, a white spirits.
We had vodka or anything
else. Um, um, so it's,
it's a difficult one. And, uh, you know,
we've tried it and it's
part of what the portfolio,
but it's so much money would go into
changing consumer behaviors and education
that for us it's nice to have for
our real opportunity is on whiskey,
which people already understand
that the already, you know,
it's a global opportunity and there's
one or two guys like Mikell, um, uh,
which is a Golway, which is, that's
what he does. He's a pushy maker. Um,
and uh, you know, I think he's trying
to do some good things as well,
but I think it will be in cocktails,
um, and understanding, you know,
maybe a signature drink that poaching
can live in to really give it so,
but it's up against, you know,
gene, uh, which is, you know, again,
it's gone crazy. Um,
but, uh, um, I, you know,
I'd like to see a future
because we have a GI who,
so it's a geographically protected
terminology that's solely from our own,
so it's there to be exploited.
But I would like to see and figure
company probably do a lot of the heavy
lifting to get it to where it needs to be.
Thank you. Um, my question
is about how do you start to,
how do you revive the a distillery?
Presume presuming that you need to have
a whiskey has been aged for 12 years or
15, maybe even 25 and I know
you're selling some 25 year
old whiskeys and then in
the same way,
how do you deal with competition?
How do you anticipate that people who
are kids today are going to love your
whiskey in 10 or 15 years and that some
other distillery is not going to come
up, come out to, it's something
revolutionary that you couldn't, you know,
deal with later.
For example,
I was thinking how Japan entered the
whiskey market in 2010 or 2014 out of the
blue and now they're kind of leading it,
getting the rewards.
How do you deal with that?
Yeah,
I said no tough questions.
Like how, how would you have whiskeys
and you're only a new distillery?
Um, um, that's a very good question.
And I was the managing director in
Cooney, uh, uh, when it was old.
I wasn't happy with it as being sold.
So I was a little bit problematic and
like demanded supply contract to be able
to stay within the industry, which
they gave. Uh, which was great.
So there's no noncompete, um, allowed me
to get back into the category. Um, and uh,
in 2012 and 13, when opportunity
came to buy, you know,
a big chunk of imagery which we
acted on. Um, so we knew quite well,
but what we focused on is changing
and making a difference on by using
innovative cost maturation to
bring that extra flavor onto,
I suppose where we're coming now.
It was full circle where, where, uh,
replacing that source whiskey
would our own whiskey now, uh,
now allows us to be truly innovative
and doing things differently. Um,
in terms of, you know, when we settle,
where were you producing whiskeys?
I mean like people would like, uh, I
suppose we were our target demographic.
Oh, you like it was an eerie, the group
that was involved with opening the city.
We sat around and said, well, what
did we find it interesting? You know,
what we like if we like and we
hope whether people like it.
So we're the toughest critics,
but we make whiskeys,
we like to drink and hope for the older
people like to drink it as well. Uh,
I go forward. How can we keep it
relevant? How we keep it exciting,
but innovating if you're asking me.
And uh, so we're laying down whiskeys,
you know, peated whiskey,
smoky whiskies, a rye whiskeys,
lots of different styles so that hopefully
we can respond to consumer interests
for different things. Um,
but it's good. It's global.
People make whiskey everywhere.
Japanese whiskeys is amazing. Uh,
Taiwanese whiskies are amazing.
Australian whiskies, you know, everywhere.
So I think it's, people are more
interested what's in the fall, you know,
rather than necessarily a, to be from a
certain country. So it puts more pressure,
but also opens up a lot of opportunities
because Irish whiskey is still quite
small. It used to be only scotch, Scotch,
Scotch, Scotch. Now it's, everyone is,
is open to trying different things.
So a lot of Whiskey,
uh, ends up getting, um,
around 45% proof.
Um,
there have been some really
interesting products that, uh,
typically higher improves. So
50, 60% cost drinks. Yep. Um,
can you talk a little bit about how that
might be in a potential direction for
you or uh, as, uh, just
industry in general?
Yeah, yeah. I think, um, um,
a lot of American whiskeys will be quite
high in alcohol. Um, and that's again,
because of the maturation. So because
they mature in very hot climates,
the actually rather than in Ireland's
where you lose alcohol into the
atmosphere, um, uh, use alcohol,
it's called the angel share.
It's our profit going up in the
air. So the smell you guys, uh,
at a whiskey warehouse is actually
alcohol disappearing into, into Asia.
What does that environmental influence
them, you know, makes whiskey what it is.
Um, so in hotter climates it
goes up rather than it goes down.
And so the longer you have it in,
wouldn't our owns the lower the alcohol
strands in America and Taiwan? It goes,
it goes off. Uh, but I think also
people want to have a four or flavor,
a stronger flavor.
And I think people's pile is gonna evolve.
And we do a lot of single cast bottling's.
Um, you can come to our distillery,
fill a single cost record from the casket,
and uh,
it could be anywhere from 62%
all the way down to, you know,
we bottled a 34 year old on was at 43.1%.
That was the actual cost rent.
We agile itself.
So it just depends if,
and what we'd like to do is cater
for a full range of tastes. Um,
and when you have a costume, you can add
water to it to get into it. You know?
So what all are whiskeys
are signature is 46%.
And the reason why we do it on
is because if you bottle it 40%,
which is the legal limits, that's the
lowest. It's obviously cheaper too. So,
but you also have to do a process.
It's called chill filtration
because if you don't do that, uh,
if you get it from hot to cold,
you get this clouding.
And little bits of a asters and fatty
acids. Coagulating and so you go, Geez,
what's floating in my whiskey?
Um,
but if you bought it at a higher
alcohol strand, you can keep them in.
So we're trying to keep,
bring more flavor in our view is why
would you take those naturally occurring
flavors? I was cause they give it
a lovely [inaudible] so, so we're,
we're all over the US and uh, uh, one
of our uh, um, our Bravo's involving,
which is a single mall boffing again,
we picked 49 and a half percent alcohol
because it delivered the best tape off I
floss.
Hi. Thank you. Um,
my question is actually related to
m trans in new product development.
So,
uh,
you've touched upon the competition
and that the big brand I tried to steal
within the category, but what's also
happening is cross category, um,
major manufacturers and small brands
competing in coming up with great ideas.
Like in the UK they've invented
the Collagen based gym,
which is as it was indeed. Yes.
I'm wondering what is happening in the
whiskey do because it's quite traditional
in terms of taste. Are there any crazy
or interesting ideas coming around?
Well,
because it's such an old industry and
there's lots of rules and regulations,
so you have to operate within.
What's interesting in Ireland,
um, is, uh, the rules,
the regulations say a hostile,
you matured in wooden barrels for three
years in a day to be legally called
Irish whiskey. Um, what if you
go to Scotland? It's old crowns.
So what you're seeing now is people
that are using different types of woods,
do you try and impart extra favor?
So chess, most acacia, cherry wood,
we even have experimented with Brazilian
hardwood sustain and be far as,
um, and it's, you know, it's weird.
It's just a weird thing cause it's like,
it just tastes like you have a grand
piano when you put your nose into it.
It's like a pace like that.
Don't ask me how,
but I was really weird. Boy. Yo, you
can do dot. Well it's, or you can,
what? We are doing a lot of collaboration
with other spirits producers,
be proper Reese, uh, order,
uh, spirit producers.
So we've used at Casa would have
been used for a Aquavit, uh,
for Jim, for, uh, vamoose,
um, for a craft beer,
um, for anything you can imagine. Um,
and you can do it because
that imparts a certain flavor,
incent borrow that you can
then extract it into whiskey.
You kind odd any flavorings and take
on nothing like natural feelings or
anything like that otherwise
can't be classified as whiskey,
but you can basically use a wooden vessel.
Dot.
Has been used to age and
mature or something else.
And we do a lot with different types
of wines and stuff like that. So,
so we're innovating where we can't
and also you can innovate how you are,
um, what raw materials you use
and even the stranger users.
So we're using a combination of
white wine, yeast and traditions,
the synergies to produce a very
flavorsome, um, um, these, um,
that you make your spirit form.
Um, okay. So you mentioned, um,
how your challenges so far have
been supply base like challenges,
but then now moving more to the
demand side. So I'm guessing that, um,
you are thinking about how to am increased
demand and one way to do that is by
scaling globally. So how
do you, I'm just curious,
how do you maintain a local
brand and make that good global?
Like how do you stay Quinn's essentially
Irish and chew to your heritage?
Like, cause this is a business
that has been inherited, right?
So how do you stay true to that
while I'm having a global appeal?
Yeah, it's a, it's a very good question.
Uh, uh, we'd probably be like here,
you guys know local type of
approach in terms of, uh,
what we do here in Dublin.
Uh,
the different things we do to try to
engage your local communities and we try
and foster cymbre type of behavior from
our importers around the world to bring
the brand to life. Um,
um, so, uh, you know,
at the core we are definitely
Arash I'm worth Dublin.
And sometimes when you go around
the world, they don't understand.
[inaudible] you know, was
dumb. I'm like, you know, they,
you know, you go to, uh, um,
New York and they still think there's
like donkeys going through the reading.
So it's a challenge. It
is a challenge, um, on,
you know what, it's easy if you live
here until understand, you know,
what the city is like,
um,
to try and capture that in an emotive
way and to bring that internationally.
It's, it's, it's a challenge. And I
wouldn't say we practice what we're,
we're working on this.
What we do is we have ours people that
we send around the world to represent the
bronze to bring it to life.
Brian Fosters a whiskey warriors is and
be like to call them because they're at
the coalface fighting to go
bottle to spread the gospel
of all team meetings, TV.
And that's going into probably
the right type of accounts, uh,
where people take pride in what they sell,
they want to,
to learn and then they can tell your
story for you. So, so, um, it's, it's,
it's an ongoing battle,
intriguingly,
purchasing whiskey to being driven by
investment decision rather than for
consumption.
And like couple of days ago
there was an article going viral,
but the Macklin selling for
nearly a million euro. Yeah.
I was wondering for people like us
who can hold whiskey for Niger for 30,
40 years at least,
uh,
what sort of recommendation would you
have in terms of what type of risk we
should be purchased?
You also disclosures
just to relate back to your companies.
Are there any specific type of a
Teeling whiskey though? Maybe we should,
or you would envisage like
surging and praise going forward?
Uh,
I,
I always encourage people to at least
buy two bottles so they can drink one
o'clock. The other one. But the core of
our range, we make risky used to be drunk.
Whiskey is for me, you know,
it's, it's, it's, it's joy.
It's social boy open and drink it.
And we positioned our core range so that
it wouldn't got her dose than people's,
uh, drinks cabinet. It was, you know,
it's, it's an affordable option.
So at the core, that's what we're all
about. Uh, what as a category, um,
uh, Irish whiskey is, is, is booming. It's
growing ahead of everyone's expectation.
So the ability to, to sell
older expressions is going
to become more limited.
You know, as more and more
collectors come in, then the, the,
there's going to be a high appreciation.
And what we're seeing is a lot of interest
in the newer distilleries like tingle
in order,
things like that.
People are just buying to sell
on and it seems to be working.
But is it a house of cards?
Any sentence,
three children and he's going to
implode. I don't know. Um, but, uh,
I think anything that has, it's like
a bit of liquid history. Um, um,
on some of the older expressions I would
expect and I can't guarantee that they
should appreciate and value as more and
more collectors come into the category
as the, as, as it gets bigger.
So it's still at the early
stages. I remember five,
10 years ago,
no one really collected Irish whiskey.
Now you go online and there's massive
communities that are all talking about it,
but it's still small rounds at the Scotch
or jumping knees. Um, and I was, uh,
we auctioned off our very first release
from the distillery on whiskey option
here,
like Hamas Scottish one.
And we did it because he wants me to
achieve the highest price so we can give
all the proceeds back to local charities
and so it gives something back.
Um,
and our bottom number one,
which is a tree year old whiskey
sold for 10,000 pounds starting,
which I thought was great,
but um, on average the,
they went for six and her parents as well.
But that's a once off never to were faces
are commercial release of our single
potstill will be coming out in October,
November of Botswana. Uh, will be price,
hopefully reasonably in offering a 50,
55 year olds. So again, drinkable. Um,
but uh, if you were to put away a
bottle, I did recommend that one.
Yeah.
Thank you so much Jack.
I never knew like coming to whiskey
Sakata Kuwait and nuggets for life.
Drink less, drink better. How have your
yeah, I'm so do less. Do Better. Yeah,
just anything less do it better.
I cannot choose. You asked the best
question. You don't have to be.
Thank you.